I was at Harvard University for 30 years
okay 30 years Claudine gay came to
Harvard University eight years ago okay
she doesn't own Harvard
University even though she's the
president I feel that this is my home
and if someone comes to my home and
violates my principles I don't leave
home because of that I will try to
change the intellectual climate we live
in for the better first off I want to
welcome you and it's been about three
months since we spoke uh we spoke last
for your wonderful second book
Interstellar and a lot has happened uh
since that time and I cannot ignore kind
of the Mastadon trampling through the
room and not ask you as uh as as someone
who is born in Israel who's raised on
Farm in Israel who is one of the most
preeminent scientists in the world but
also a very proud Jew and as am I and I
I don't make any apologies for that I
was in Israel a mere two weeks before
the October 7th Hamas terrorist attacks
I was in Tel Aviv I was in southern
Israel I was in jeruselam and I was very
close because it was Russia Shana AI I
actually got to be very close with a lot
of uh Palestinians Arabs because they
were the ones working while Jews were
enjoying their holiday so I actually had
many meals with with pal Ians um shared
many rides with them on public and and
private transport and U had no inkling
of what would happen and the uh the
Insight that I think we need to start
with before we turn to to Harvard and
then eventually to the uh the subject
that I originally invited you to speak
about which is your area of expertise
which is this Interstellar meteorite
which is receive some push back from the
community as as happens um some of it
fair some of it possibly not fair uh
we'll talk about that so three things on
the agenda today first of all AI um I
need to give you a chance to just share
your thoughts as as a man of science as
a man of conscience and as a Jew how
have you been dealt affected by the
events of October 7th well let me first
clarify this is not a war between the
Palestinians and Israel it's a war
between the Hamas and Israel and there
is a clear distinction because uh given
the charter of the Hamas there cannot be
peace cannot be a two-state solution H
the Hamas calls for uh the removal of
Israel for killing all citizens of
Israel there is no room for compromise
and therefore anyone that s sides with
uh a terrorist organization which
basically aims to annihilate uh the
state of Israel kill all all the Jews
rather than reach a compromise is
basically advocating violence um and
that has nothing to do with political
opinion I want to clarify that um you
know my wife is uh peace seeking uh
Israeli and she was always on the left
advocating for finding a resolution to
the Israeli Palestinian uh conflict but
uh what happened on October 7th was uh
rape of women killing of babies one of
whom you know I I will not get into the
details there is actually a film about
it but it was the most violent uh Act of
barbarism Against Humanity basically
killing people uh that have nothing to
do with a military conflict these are
civilians at their homes and um in a way
you know sort of like the Reckoning
after 911 you know we should all condemn
such an act now then you ask yourself
how is it possible that 20
student organizations at Harvard
University would cheer up and say that
the
victims uh deserved it irrespective of
political views nobody should
celebrate killing of innocent
civilians for any political purpose and
so that is a distortion of uh the moral
compass and you ask yourself how did we
get there well it's obviously a result
of social media where uh that polarizes
Society but you can't just uh relate it
to that there is something wrong with
Academia and yesterday I was actually in
Washington DC I was jogging at 6: am uh
on the Arlington
Bridge with a backdrop of a beautiful uh
Sunrise uh and a few a few hours later
uh Harvard's president along with two
other university presidents uh was
testifying uh in Capitol Hill where I I
met with other people um
and she was asked claing gay was asked
whether uh calling for a genocide of
Jews should be considered harassment yes
or
no and she said it depends on the
context and not only she but the other
two
presidents and to me
that is a terrible message because there
is no doubt that the genocide of any
group of people should be condemned she
should have said
no but instead she said if it doesn't
translate into
action then uh you know we have to deal
on with it on a case-by casee basis and
what does it mean action that Jews will
be killed on
campus on only then would you consider
it as a violation of the code of ethics
I mean obviously a lot of students feel
unsafe and classes are disrupted by
demonstrators all the time right now at
Harvard University so obviously you can
advocate for freedom of speech but there
is a limit uh if someone C comes on
campus and H Praises Hitler and calls
for killing of Jews obviously that is
you know that person crosses the line
there is a limit uh a university is an
educational institution okay and that
means you need to educate people what
does it mean to educate people it means
that to tell them when they are wrong
not to allow them to say things that are
harmful to other people and obviously
this is all recognized in some context
of gender diversity ethnic diversity but
not in this case of the Jews and you ask
yourself how is that possible uh after
the Holocaust where six million people
were killed I mean don't we have those
sensitivities and the Provost of Harvard
Alan Garber was sitting just behind
claing gay when he she gave this
testimony so I wouldn't say that the
dysfunctional leadership at harbard uh
is just a matter of people not
understanding uh the Jewish history
because there are some Jews involved in
in allowing this to happen like the
provest of Harvard like uh the head of
the board uh of Trustees um you know
priser and it shouldn't take a Jew right
it shouldn't take a Jew look the same
people those same provosts the pritsker
family they were justifiably outraged at
the uh murder The Death of George Floyd
I remember three years ago or more and
we received on this campus basically
shut down campus we shut down journals
we shut we protested uh on behalf of the
you know solidarity with
African-Americans on campuses and that
was swiftly and roundly condemned and we
had teachings and so forth I I tweeted
out today you know thank God basically
that UCS isn't as prestigious as Harvard
or MIT because when you're at an
institution like a Harvard like a Yale
like MIT like Penn you have a long way
down when you were the president of that
University that Harvard you know I I
hate to admit it although we all know
it's true Harvard is the gold standard
okay what happens at Harvard affects the
rest of the world not just higher
education not just the ivy league just
as what happens in California
academically for under uh for students
in in schools dominates the rest of the
nation because we have the biggest
population so we have the very very uh
bright Spotlight that burns on campuses
now here on my own campus yeah go ahead
yeah no I just wanted to add that you
know even on the in the context of
freedom of speech which uh was mentioned
by the leadership of Harvard Harvard
ranks very low because there were
professors who were fired for just
suggesting H you know that the
women give
birth uh and and that was considered
inappropriate in the current
intellectual climate but on the other
hand you know calling for uh the
destruction of Israel and and and
genocide of Jews is not considered a
deviation from what is acceptable and
there is freedom of speech the first
group of people that should have it are
tenur professors that's the whole
meaning of tenure so how is it that
there is this counil culture to
basically remove those who you do not
agree with including speakers uh you
know from the other side of the
political Spectrum I think that has the
consequence of polarizing Society even
further because at an academic
institution you must must be taught to
listen to have a dialogue with people
that disagree with you that is the
fundamental ethics of Academia and that
is being violated you know I have this
sense that it's just like
1984 of Orwell where you know some
people in Academia are advocating for
principles but are violating them by
their own actions so they are on the one
hand virtue signaling as if they are in
favor of diversity but anyone that
disagrees with them on a m on on a
particular subject is not allowed on
campus and you know so just like George
Orwell mentioned the party line uh which
basically said war is peace and the
ignorance is strength you know you you
are advocating for something and then
violating it yourself and I find that to
be completely inappropriate especially
for intelligent people I mean you can
imagine politicians doing that for
political benefits but within
Academia it's just unacceptable because
we are educating the next generation of
leaders you know especially at Harvard
we we have to show some moral compass uh
when we direct them into their adulthood
so I really am who said it but yeah no I
forget who said it but there's nothing
that's so ludicrous that it can't be
believed by the world's most
intellectual individuals of which
universities are a part now I think
universities have a special Duty as you
say because everything in in society is
Downstream from universities in other
words every journalist went to a
university every politician went to a
university every um every you know Tech
worker every every Professor went to a
university we have a huge amount of
Leverage on society and since the 1970s
uh and and Beyond we've become obsessed
with with you know what's called
critical thinking and and basically
destroying a lot of what you know the
currency that Academia built up over the
past hundred years and I I think it's I
I feel like it is a sea change when I
see on campus here at UC San Diego the
Isis flag being raised to intimidate you
know Senators before a student Senate
meeting when I see you know people uh
needing police escorts to leave a
student Senate meeting uh Jewish
students only uh when I see medical
workers the been ladin letter that was
spread around the Tik Tok you just think
about it where a lot of young people
just argued that uh it now makes sense
sense for what Badin was saying you know
that these are corrosive elements that
will that could destroy our society they
could lead to violence they could lead
to a a repetition of what the history H
did so so badly do you think was going
through I mean to the extent that you
know her at all I mean I I was
disappointed I mean they all had a
script they all said essentially the
same thing president gay your president
had an opportunity because she didn't
actually wasn't president she hasn't
been president for that long although
she's obviously re received a ton of of
of ir Etc but what do you think was
going through the minds of of the MIT
president and and the pen president why
can't they why is it so difficult I mean
what forces would conspire and at my
graduate institution Christina Paxton at
Brown University ivy league as well uh
she refused to say that you know uh
prepared remarks in Her speech she was
going to say that you should feel free
to wear a keepa a yamaka as well as a
hijab and changed it because there were
chance that she's you know a part uh of
genocide uh taking you know benefiting
from because they won't boycott divest
in sanction now by the way um would you
be allowed let's say BDS were to pass
and would you be allowed because you do
you still have dual citizenship or or I
I know that my my my uh colleagues would
not that are in Israel they would be
forbidden to come to campus so I find
this medieval I find this like a
throwback to the Dark Ages you could
talk about wanting to boycott companies
fine but to to to sanction and to
boycott individuals that is an
anti-intellectual pursuit in my opinion
Al I think what do you think was going
through president Gay's mind yeah you
could see that the answers reflect a
very careful dance around the legal
issues because if she were to admit uh
that calling for genocide uh is
inappropriate then the next question
would be what do you do about it and
then if she says Okay since it's in
conflict with the code of conduct within
Harvard University we have to discipline
those students she doesn't want to go
that far and moreover she doesn't want
to be sued or legally um because of in
inaction in past events so I think she
was advised by uh lawyers to say what
she said but that is very disappointing
because leadership is all about H
crafting your own words in a sincere
authentic fashion uh and actually
following the principles that you
advocate for and what you find here is
uh situation where universities are
failing uh to show any moral compass and
um I'm I'm very disappointed because
that's not the environment that I was
hoping for and actually if you think
about it before October 7 a lot of
people had this illusion that their
friends on the left will fight for them
if a situation like that H Rises but
instead what you see is a situation
where uh you know that you could call it
anti-Semitism I mean you basically
uh some people don't really care about
lives of Jews um and and I find that
amazing you know because some of them
are actually Jews and these yeah so so
uh something is wrong and by the way it
doesn't really just I think it's a in a
way it looks to me like craziness okay
like loss of Sanity in the context of
our moral compass and uh we need to get
back to the B basic principles which is
to
respect everyone and you know I was um
under I was at a dinner uh in New York
city hosted by Bill akman and he
actually is a very strong critic of
claudin gay but there were some Howard
faculty there and at an event um uh
General Patos was speaking at that
dinner he was talking about the
geopolitical future of the Middle East
after the Israel Hamas war and again I'm
emphasizing this is really the Hamas War
it's not the Palestinians we maybe it
will be there will be an opportunity to
establish something more stable in the
future after destroying the Hamas but uh
but at any event uh so he was giving his
forecast which sounded gloomy actually
and uh the uh curator of the Museum of
Modern Art uh was there and Anton Paula
Antonelli and um she summarized her
vision in in three words she said love
the aliens now what she meant is you
should love those that are different
than you and for me you know
scientifically speaking I actually am
looking forward to an meeting another
civilization that is smarter than us
because perhaps it will inspire us to do
better it's just like finding a smarter
student in your class and um for other
people it's a threat because you want to
always believe that you are the most
intelligent but you see the situation
right now we are wasting a lot of
resources effort on military conflicts
um2 trillion dollar a Year by the way
and if we were to direct it to space
exploration we could send a space probe
you know a cube set towards every star
in the Milky Way galaxy billions of them
within this Century it's just a matter
of priorities and for some reason uh and
you know I always ask there was two
months ago there was a a presentation of
a play that was written by a
playright Josh ret uh about my research
current research so he wrote a play that
he wants to feature Off Broadway in New
York City and in the play uh the main
character which is me uh asks the
question why is childlike bullying more
prevalent than childlike curiosity you
know that's really the underlying we
have that people prefer to hate each
other rather than to work together
towards a better future